Yeah,
democracy can mean a lot of different
things,
but at mit,
a bomb to be a democracy,
we have to have a system that involves
ultimately the judgment of the people
and the regular judgment worthwhile.
It has to be a judgment where people
after console one another,
I think have a democracy to call them in
democracy where people don't have a
respect across their differences for the
co equal people.
On the other side of issues,
I don't think that's democracy.
Whatever it may be,
and I think that whatever form you're
voting is whether you have direct
representation,
whether you're have indirect
representation with a proportional
representation,
what he would like by districts where
they would like by winner take all,
whatever it may be.
Whatever your voting system is.
Democracy has mainly worked,
precedes the voting democracy,
is that deliberation amongst citizens
and involve citizens.
Beliefs that what we have to think
matters and should matter to each other
and our ability and our comfort level
with sitting and talking and also
listening,
trying to persuade others,
but first log in to try to persuade.
Awesome.
Really allowed the opportunity.
Really listen to what they have to say
is they have dismissing it out of him.
That to me is democracy.
It's difficult.
It's rough and tumble.
It doesn't always get quick and
efficient answers,
but it is the only thing I think I've
been really do in which people actually
participate in governing themselves.